uh got you guys some gifts I see each
other yes trying to one-up Jack I see
Jack didn't bring his gifts he didn't no
he didn't well then of course I won up
here
what do you mean well because because
you mentioned when we were getting Jack
on you like you bastards why are they
getting Jack on before me yeah the
[ __ ]
we were gonna get you one eventually
because I met up with you guys three
years ago and you were like we're gonna
do a podcast really cause I'm like
and then I'm like cool I'll be a guest
six nine we're saying yeah episode six
and that was like episode 10 we're like
wow that's very uh camping in the UK and
like a [ __ ] nothing
it's funny because when you said like oh
come on I'm like episode 69 I'm just
like Felix is Gonna Come on because
we're never gonna reach episode 16 yeah
wow you're really positive about this
[ __ ] podcast reaching 69 episodes
is it PewDiePie merch
that's why I said
I gotta eat some whiskey
you know this one yeah this is really
nice actually it's very nice whiskey
I've I've been terrible with whiskey so
I'm perfect
one of your favorites uh yeah it's one
of my favorite it's a bit different
because it's uh aged in the forest by
the way oh wow it's got a bit what's the
flavor what's the preferred way of
drinking this would you recommend just
straight right yeah
rocks what do you mean I don't know I
don't know whiskey you can get those
like whiskey like Stone cubes yeah I use
those I feel like I have to get into
whiskey dilated
thank you very much I appreciate it yeah
this is awesome yeah
whiskey glass that has like a small
opening so you can smell it and then
okay I'll have to ask you what those are
I have to get something I don't have any
good whiskey glasses Joey yeah I wanted
to give you my favorite Radiohead album
which was in rainbows oh [ __ ] I couldn't
get it so I got you my favorite cigaross
album oh [ __ ] yeah yeah we got I
actually don't have this one yet I know
we also have to blow the cover yeah yeah
hell yeah I actually don't have this one
yet Aki you showed me your collection oh
really
smart and smart [ __ ] yeah thanks so much
it's a good one yeah I love this album
which I think all our guests
by the way yeah okay yes I'm glad you
didn't get it yeah
oh god what have you got for gone yeah
before we get demonetized
[ __ ] is gone yeah these are like the
best we ever got so far they're just
surrounded by what made you want to
bring us gifts that's so nice yeah I
don't know
oh is that what I think it is oh my God
Felix you can't give him that oh my God
he's never gonna let that thing thank
you so much you said you weren't
interested I was like yes [ __ ] take it
he's gonna kill someone he's gonna be in
the trash case
thank you so much I'm gonna fidget with
this yeah when you said you like
fidgeting
yeah okay no no I have like my training
how did you get into this uh yeah it's a
bit cringe isn't it
I've never seen like I never knew about
this until you started getting I've seen
it I just thought it was like a thing
people do on YouTube yeah like the
corners what is it is it Counter Strike
but people have the knives
three years later how the [ __ ] do you do
it what's the like technique yeah uh
yeah you you just fiddle like whatever
you want with it that's so sick [ __ ]
that
it's kind of like pen spinning in a
sense yeah yeah that's that's why like
I've seen Felix do it I'm like I could
get into this yeah because you can paint
spins yeah yeah oh my God he's never
gonna put it down all right it's better
if I don't keep it that's so sick it's
fun fiddling tool basically you like
fiddle that's yeah this is this is why
like the whole reason I learned how to
spin a pen was because I'm gonna fiddle
let's at least make it look cool so now
that you got me this I'm like [ __ ] you
can't watch anything yeah yeah
that's fine thank you so much yeah these
gifts are [ __ ] awesome yeah thank you
again oh yeah thank you nice that's so
nice oh yeah all right so my turn yeah
um which figure do you want
[Music]
is pretty sick
who's have you seen by the way I don't
know I it was sure like top anime if you
had to give like list off some of your
favorites uh
uh favorite we're obliged to talk to you
about anime yeah
foreign
I gotta think a second uh favorite
I don't watch recently
are you a little more of an anime watch
or a mongerator yeah no I watch anime
yeah uh
[ __ ]
why is Death Note the only thing
is it's a really good show how did I
spill this all the way down I don't know
how do they do that I remember watching
Naruto back in the day and I was like no
one else knows about Naruto It's like
because no one was watching it outside
yeah it was so underground yeah it was I
felt so cool watching that like yo this
is this is nobody has ever watched
Naruto it doesn't really happen it
doesn't exist I had so much uh yeah it
anime felt underground back in the day
yeah somebody like walls yeah yeah I
remember Clannad was the [ __ ]
good [ __ ] well actually like one of my
favorite video of yours is the one where
you talked about blam oh really yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's a really good one I haven't read
that yet
it was so like out it was so out there
because I'm like wait Felix reads manga
and also it's blam yeah
huh you're like yeah yeah I really like
lamb too but like no one really talks
about it's really like yeah underground
yeah that's a truly underground yeah
yeah is it really yeah I feel like the
longest time I confused blaming against
together I don't know
sci-fi you know very gritty dances a
ride against is a [ __ ] ride dude yeah
he dances
I don't want to see that I mean in
Japanese is pronounced yeah
diamonds are really good that's probably
my favorite manga I made a video on him
too busy making amvs to watch out of it
honestly I missed I missed the AMV era
so much no I don't know that should pop
off with like Tick Tock and [ __ ] like
that yeah I mean the dots yeah it's like
when they [ __ ] take Breaking Bad
clips and put some [ __ ] music over it in
the like epic Walter White moment yeah
I'm Heisenberg what the [ __ ] is this
because like I don't even call it AMV
anymore this is just
yeah yeah because like most of the time
it's the same it's this like not saying
they're not like talented editors but
most of the time it looks exactly the
same you take like you take a scene from
anime you uh put it through this uh you
put it through the 60 FPS filter you
know so it looks super smooth yeah and
then you zoom into the eye and then it's
like and then you do like the 12 the 12
transition yeah no that's everything
like gaussian blur 100 just every yeah
five or some Nightcore in the background
yeah oh the Nightcore oh the Night Court
here God I don't miss the Nightcore era
I still listening
Owl City Nightcore